giving away [ __ ] for free is an  incredible way to start to monetize what  did he say Let Me Explain you do one  wedding for free and you're good there's  seven other people at that wedding  they're about to get married and you get  their business it's the best word of  mouth business ever this notion of not  giving stuff away for free is insanity  so you want to get paid to speak at  events go do a bunch of them for free  like I did and now I get paid a lot but  not because I did it for free because I  was awesome at it right you have to be  good too like you could give away a free  DJing at a wedding and you might ruin  the wedding no referrals  right right like if you can execute it's  easy but then people get romantic and  philosophical about it that's my time  that's what I actually sell you're not  entitled right so give put out put out  the work and the network effect will  happen if you're good enough